POLICIES AND PERSONNEL ANTEDATE
THE CITY'S REGULATOR AGREED AND
GRANTED A PROBATIONARY LICENSE.
U.S. SUPPORTS NATO.
CORRESPONDENT KEVIN CORKE HAS
MORE ON THAT FROM THE
MUCH SMALLER GDP.
SHOULD PAY THE SAME AS GERMANY.
>> TO THE DENIZENS OF THE
PALMETTO STATE IT WAS MUSIC TO
THE EARS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP TALKING TOUGH
ABOUT NATO, CALLING OUT GERMANY
FOR WHAT HE SAYS IS ITS LACK OF
FINANCIAL COMMITMENT TO THE
ALLIANCE AND SUGGESTING NOW
MAYBE THE TIME FOR THE U.S. TO
PULL THE PURSE STRINGS.
>> IT'S ALL WONDERFUL AND WE
LIKE TO HELP OUT, BUT IT HELPS
THEM.
THEY ARE IN EUROPE.
>> THE PRESIDENT'S CRITIQUE THAT
NEW.
HE SLAMMED THE ALLIANCE ON
TWITTER, WARNING THAT CHANGE IS
MINISTERS IN BRUSSELS AND
>> MORE AND MORE ALLIES ARE AT
2% OF GDP FOR DEFENSE.
BUT THEY ALSO AGREE THAT WE HAVE
TO DO MORE.
>> NATO HAS 29 MEMBER STATES BUT
ONLY EIGHT COUNTRIES, INCLUDING
THE U.S., SPEND THE AGREED TO 2%
BUDGET.
PARTNERS LIKE GERMANY FALL WELL
SHORT OF ADOPTING THE
PRESIDENT'S THREAT TO MATCH
THEIR SPENDING LEVELS.
A SENIOR ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIALS SAY THE PRESIDENT'S
RHETORICAL PRESSURE ISN'T LIKELY
TO BE BACKED UP WITH IMMEDIATE
POLICY CHANGES, BUT THE RISK FOR
THE ALLIANCE IS ALL TOO REAL.
PARTICULARLY FOR EUROPEAN
CAPITALS TO WATCH WARILY AS
>> IN 2018 WHEN THE NUMBERS ARE
FINISHED WE WILL HAVE THE
LARGEST INCREASE IN DEFENSE
SPENDING BY OUR NATO COUNTRIES
OUTSIDE OF THE UNITED STATES
SINCE THE COLD WAR.
>> THE RHETORICAL PRESSURE BY
THE PRESIDENT IS SEEN IN SOME BY
A PROXY ISSUE FOR WHAT HE
CONSIDERS UNFAIR EUROPEAN PARADE
DOWN MY TRADE PRACTICES,
SOMETHING WHICH WILL GET A GREAT